[Music]
hello there look it's an additional PS
plus video this month there are 19 games
on PS plus essential that you may have
missed that you can download right now
the thing is they're going to be removed
from the service on May 9th so you don't
have a lot of time to add these to your
collection and yes if you add these to
your gaming collection before May 9th
they will still be there after they are
removed from the service they act just
the same as essential tier games claim
them to keep them they'll be there as
long as you are subscribed because PS
plus is a little bit messy let me
explain which games I'm referring to
it's not the monthly game downloads and
it's not the game catalog that is
updated mid-month the PS plus collection
was started back in 2020 when new PS5
owners with PS plus were given a back
catalog of 20 of the best games from the
PS4 ERA with slight improvements like
frame rate patches and stability updates
what was really impressive back then was
the sheer number of PlayStation first
party games from God of War to days gone
a great way for new PlayStation 5 on us
to instantly build a collection of games
from day one but players quickly
realized that PS4 owners could claim
those games by logging in on a friend's
PS5 and I don't think Sony liked that
plus since then a few deals with
third-party Publishers have lapsed so
games like Persona 5 have already been
removed unless you claim them of course
here are the 19 games that you can still
claim before May 9th God of War 2018
bloodborne Monster Hunter World Final
Fantasy XV Royal Edition Fallout 4
Mortal Kombat 10 Uncharted 4 a thief's
end Ratchet and Clank days gone until
dawn Detroit become human Battlefield 1
Infamous Second Son Batman Arkham Knight
The Last Guardian The Last of Us
remastered Resident Evil biohazard Call
of Duty Black Ops 3 zombie Chronicles
Edition and Crash Bandicoot the insane
Trilogy if you need help finding these
games let me help you out I checked if I
claimed them this morning simply select
your PS plus icon and scroll scroll down
to these panels here scroll right until
you see the PlayStation Plus collection
click view games and here they are right
now in mind there are 18 I don't know
where Uncharted vanished to oh and don't
worry about downloading these games
simply click on them and you'll have an
add to library button I've already
claimed mine which is why I don't have
it here please spread the word we don't
have a lot of time to get these games in
people's Collections and you may not
feel like playing them right now but one
day you may want to go back and play a
bit of Batman again in case you were
wondering like me I added all these up
and they were worth 404 pounds here in
the UK and over 500 in the US so yeah
it's worth claiming right May 9th draws
the end of the PlayStation Plus
collection I'm Adam you're awesome it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you